[Music]
so
i first learned to play poker age
21
yeah it was 2005. i just graduated uni
didn't really know what i wanted to do
thought i was going to carry on in
physics but i decided to take a gap year
because
when i first started taking physics i
was like oh i'm definitely doing this
this is so interesting i love it but
then
the more time i got to spend with like
uh phd students or even people doing
their masters they seemed
i don't know they just didn't seem very
happy and
i don't know just personality wise i was
wondering if it actually was gonna work
for me
because all i really wanted to do was go
out partying and clubbing and go you
know see rock shows metal shows and i
was also still wanting to be a rock star
at the time and i was like uh i just
don't know if this is gonna quite work
me sitting in a lab you know fiddling
around with lasers so decided to take a
gap here and
i think i signed up oh i was doing like
random like goth modeling sometimes
and i as one does
in their gap year right well i you know
just any way i could make some money and
i thought
i don't know i enjoyed dressing up in my
my heavy metal costumes as often as
possible and i was like if i can get
paid to do that that'd be great
i also got paid to be a cage dancer
in
rock clubs in london yeah well you know
i was admiring the the boots
on the way in this is uh the shoeless
household so thank you for accommodating
this is not my least messy sock ever
these are gray and pink striped socks
with hearts all over them so yes it's
it's well it's like the hard exterior
the goth death metal exterior and then
like the the soft sweet
inside do you understand how much paint
i'm in actually the fact that this is
these i have so many like most of my
socks are black
i just grabbed whatever i needed to so
goth modeling which i also did during my
gap year totally lying i'm kidding i'm
kidding
and i wish i i wish i could have but
goth modeling cage dancing
and
and then and then yes so
i think i signed up for this like
website that
would advertise different tv shows or
modeling opportunities that kind of
thing and i remember seeing an ad which
said something like could you use your
powers of skill and deception to win 100
000 pounds on tv
and seeing as i was you know rapidly
getting pretty damn broke because
dancing in a rock club cage doesn't pay
you anything really and i had some
student debt mounted up but really
didn't want to get a real job for you
know my parents were like you have to
like what are you doing you've moved to
london get a job
so i was like okay i'm gonna
this seems reasonable i wanted to try
being on tv
i like game shows this seems like a game
show i'll apply
turns out they wouldn't tell us what
what it was that we were applying for
because they needed to keep it a secret
but turns out it was a reality show that
was looking for five beginners
at poker to teach them how to play and
the sort of loose scientific premise was
they were looking for five different
personality types uh to see which you
know is most suited for the game
and so i got selected for that what was
your personality type
they called me the professor
which i most certainly don't know i
could see it i could see it i i
literally turned up in
skin tight tiger print spandex self-made
trousers now did you do that because
they had put you in the professor
category was that a rebellion an act of
rebellion or did that just
no i mean that was genuinely how i
dressed it was style emoting no it was
it was my genuine appearance as i said i
lived and breathed metal sounds good for
tv
right and i think that's probably why
they selected me honestly like i was
strange very very overconfident to the
point of like cocky
21 year old
brat
unheard of with 21 year olds yeah so i
just thought i was the smartest person
in the world and i think i even said
something like that in the interview
like they auditioned and they're like oh
we're definitely bringing yeah this is
going to be a good one and i didn't
disappoint because i ended up having a
complete meltdown on the show like
so glad this is not on the internet
basically on the final i think we played
like seven
preliminary rounds where we would the
five of us would play yeah and then like
that would accumulate points and those
points would translate into chips for
the final game where we would play for
the hundred thousand
and i was winning you know i was leading
going into that and clearly i had a
knack for the game
and i remember the the hosts and the
the professionals that they bought on
the show to teach us were like oh you're
definitely going to win you know you are
the most talented at this so i was so
sure i was going to win this thing
and then
i ended up making
not to get too technical but basically i
misread my hand
oh no i didn't i misread the board
i made a straight on the river the
opponent bet i was so excited i was like
i raise which was basically all my chips
and then i looked at the board again and
noticed there were four diamonds out
there
and i didn't have i might i had two
black cards
and audibly went ah
no i'm not i'm i'm no professional but
is that what one would call a tell yes
that is that is a tell
do not do that
and
my opponent it was a really nice guy
called lee
was like well i guess she doesn't have a
diamond
and he's like i'm all in
and instead of again keeping my my cool
or anything i just started crying like
melted down the producers are
high-fiving
yeah they were literally and and
they're like oh liv what's the matter
tell us more and i was like you know
makeup everywhere i think i i like run
away from the table they try and follow
me with a camera it was just you know
classic reality tv meltdown stuff so
that was my intro to poker but i just
completely fell in love with the game
and funnily enough while i was in the
during the filming of that which took
two months
i went to a local card club in london to
try and get some practice
and
they had this
now sort of infamous this five pound
rebuy so you know it was the cheapest
tournament they had what is a rebuy a
rebuy means that for the first hour or
so if you bust out you can just buy back
in again so considering it was only five
pound entry you can imagine it's just
pandemonium everyone's going in every
single hand and people will easily like
spend like 100 pounds in their entry
overall you know 20 rebuys good for the
house yeah but i turned up with 10
pounds because i was like well it's a
five pound tournament why would i ever
need more than you know five pound for
the entry and five pound to buy a drink
and that will be my my day so you're
like a player in a video game with
two lives where everybody else has like
a hundred lives right yeah and most
people were doing that yes
only for the first hour then once that
period ends then if you bust out you're
out yeah so anyway i go and this is the
first tournament i ever play and i enter
this thing
somehow get through this
carnage period in the first hour the
zombies i think i did keep yeah i think
i did buy once with my other five pounds
so i didn't buy a drink
and anyway i ended up winning it
ended up playing until five in the
morning it was like 120 people in it and
i came home i remember just having this
you know they paid me out in tens and
20s i think 750 pounds or something like
that which was
more money so i'd never seen that amount
of cash before just so much money and i
remember going home to my boyfriend at
the time and waking him up at 5am and
just throwing the cash on him
like this is the best thing ever this is
my game and i must be the best in the
world like you know it's my first ever
tournament basically and i win it so
even though the tv show did not go well
and i didn't win 100 grand i'd already
got the bug basically from that little
win
you